[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
اخباريا خاص ومتنوع وبقاع سريعا ومختلف
جدا نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق وبين
العاشر والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم وسوره
الكامله البدايه من العناوين
قد لا تميت الشعارات الديكتاتور لكن
الجراه والعصيان يشقان ايراني من جدران
الشوارعها الى ساحه جامعتها
ايران تدفعوا بالحوثيين الى عمليه انصهار
ما حزب الله لاكمال عقد الهلال من الشاوي
من اليمن الى لبنان وفي ملفات الساعه 06
خشيه من مساجيه بوتين وتجنبنا لغرقا جديد
اتفاق الحبوب محاوله انتفاخ البريه على
البحر الاسود
بين المسرحين والمعلمين والرسوم هلا يغرق
تويتر الون ماسك في نفسي حوض المغسله التي
حملها
[موسيقى]
وسطى جنازات النشطاء ومراسم تشيعهم
والخارجين على حمله القمع في العصيان
اجتماعيا وثقافيه
بوجي لون جديد تقف ايران امام موجه
احتجاجا ثانيه تستلده من الرصاص الحيه
والضرب بالهراوات قوه رفض واصرارا على
السيد خارج جمهوريه الخميني وربما عليها
[موسيقى]
اذا كما تابعنا لم يعد التلويح بالحرس
الثوري رابعا ومات شعار الموت للديكتاتور
تقليدا ملازما للتظاهرات يستهدف المرشد
معنايا والاهم بشكل مباشر لكن للانظمه
الشموليه في الازمات الداخليه رائع خارجيه
تجنبها الاجابه على الاسئله الملحوها حتى
على الوجديه الشعر جاهز وان لم يعد انه
الشيطان الاكبر امريكا التي يتهممها
المرشد الايراني
مجددا بالمناسبه قاسم سليماني في ربطه
الاحتجاجات بامريكا لكن كلاهما تحرق
صورهما وبشكل اليومي» من شده الغضب اطلق
عليها النار هذه المراه
[تصفيق]
لكن سؤال لا مشروع ايضا من اين يخرج
المتظاهرون ومن هم وماذا يريدون ومن هو
عدوهم او خصمهم
يخرجون من شوارع المدن الايرانيه ومن
مدارسها ومن جامعاتها يريدون الحريه خصمهم
داخلي ولا تعنيهم ذكرى اقتحام السفاره
الامريكيه لا من قريب ولا من بعيد
عقب القبض عليهم ارسل الاطفال لمراكز علم
نفس بحسب الروايه الرسميه لكنها في
الحقيقه مواقع غسل دماغ بي حسب منظمات
حقوقيه والهدف هو اعاده التلاميذ للبيئه
المدرسيه بشكل افضل وهذا بروايه السلطان
بينما الهدف الحقيقي هو اجبار الاطفال على
استطيع على بيانات تعاقد بالولاء للدوله
المفارقه ان اليوم كما اسلفنا ذكر اقتحام
السفاره الامريكيه يوم التلميذ في ايران
ظاهره الاحتفال بالطلاب اما في الباحه
الخلفيه اعتقال
بنقالي
[موسيقى]
يمك
ومتنوعه
على الاطلاق منذ ثورتي
في الاشهر السته الاولى من العام الحالي
ومن مختلف الاثنيات والقوميات لا يجددون
مطالبهم يوميا طلاب الجامعات رياضيون اوام
ومشاهير وتحولت الازقه والشرفات الى ساحات
وما كان فيها وبينها للخوف وان كان المهدد
الحرس الثوري وقائده
استغفر تجاوز الحرس ووصل الى المرشد شعار
الموت للديكتاتور سمع في مدينه قم قم
الحوزاء العلميه وايضا في مشهد مسقط راس
خامنئي وحاضنه الحرس الثوري والاخطر رصد
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تمديد من قلب
النظام ضد راس النظام تنجيد بالقمع من
عاملين لنا في القضاء والصناعات
البتروكيماويه
وتمديد من الجنود
يوسف
في الحرس الثوري ليست خائنه كما تقول بل
خائفه ولكنها تواجه وصلت رسالتها ورسائل
وغيرها ايضا بشعره ورسومات الى الحرس
الثوري وسنعود لها بعد قليل بان تدركوا
السلطات ان الانتفاضات ليست ثوره لكن
القلق انها لا تخمد ثوره على الثوره وهذا
ليس تكهنا وانما خبراء يرون نقاط تشابهن
بين الثورتين وحتى الحرس الثوري الذي تعز
صحيفه ليمون ضد المتظاهرين الى خشيته على
نظام نفسه حسب الصحيفه يتخوف من تكرار
تجربه نظام الشاه الذي تنازل للمتظاهرين
باعتقال متهمين بالفساد واطلاق سجناء
سياسيين ولكن كانت نتيجته حتميه لانهيار
في مازق النظام الكبير وربما الاكبر منذ
ثوره
1979 لا تنازل لمطالب المحتاجين تشدد
السلطات قبضتها المفرطه بالعنف لاحباط اي
سنن تغيير وهنا لا نتحدث عن خمس انتفاضات
الكبرى بل عن ثوره تشرين في العراق
وحزب الله العراقي جلبهم الحرس الثوري الى
المشهد لكن المشهد سبقهم الشباب ان
يتجراؤوا على المستحيل يسقط وعمامات
الملالي الثابت منذ عام 79
ايه النظام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تجربه الشعب الغاضب تتكرر وبفارقي اربعه
عقود شعار الموت يعود من الشاه الى
الديكتاتور
اين استمع مشاهدينا
[تصفيق]
وايضا يرسم على جدران شوارع طهران بجراه
وبدون قيود لما يوفر اذن المحتجون فكره
الا ووظفوها في خدمه صرختهم فرضت اجرتهم
نفسها على اللوحات وعلى الجرافيت ومن
ايران الى جميع انحاء العالم سوف يطول
الانترنت ورغم جميع محاولات السلطات
لصديقها لم تمنع مواكبه الحراك الايرانيه
من الخارج المراه الحياه الحريه الذي يملا
شوارع ايران رفع في فرانكفورت وروسيا على
جدران المدينه في مكسيكو سيتي الرساله
وصلت الى السفاره الايرانيه باسم ايقونه
الانتفاضه مهسه
الكرتون الشهير تضامن في ميلانو مع نساء
ايران وانتفاضتهن وزخ مرتضى في باريس اكبر
ربما يغنيها اعتزام فرنسا
على احد الشوارع
جدارياتنا كهذه باتت ترسم ملامح شوارع
العاصمه الفرنسيه وهذه هي الصوره اتسعت
لها مدن مختلفه اما الصرخه بالصوت فكانت
اعلى من ايران
[موسيقى]
المفتوحه على امل جديد وصلت من طهران ومن
مدن ايران الى جائزه جراني
اغنيه من اجل ومن اجلها الشاب شروين
حاجبور يقبع خلف القضبان
مصيرنا متوقع غير ان المفاجاه كانت النظام
بتخطي اغنيه الحدود وكسرها المحدود
استثنائيه اخرى للالتفاضه الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
براويه صغيره
ضربه فور لاقت الحلول الجاهزه والمعالجه
الاعتياديه في ايران ملاحقته وسجنه
وملاحقته اغنيته واشطبها من المواقع خطوه
اضافيه ايضا اعتياديه اتخذتها السلطات بحق
مغني يعد اكثر الجراه حتى من بورك توماجا
صالحي هو لما يخاطب السلطان لم يكشف حال
الايرانيين بلخص خامنئي باغنيه ساله فيها
ان كان يشعر بحال البلاد وان كان يشعر
بالمشردين والفقراء
الاعتقال الضغط والتعذيب مع توماج غير
كافن فجاءت اللمس الخاصه اعتراف قصري
للمغني نمطي للنظام الذي سجل اعلمه في
2009 وحتى 2019
355 اعترافا على شاشاته
لودو ستار
لكن ان كانت الانتفاضه ان تحملوا شعارا
يمثلها فحتما مشاهدينا سيكون هذا هو
الشعار مؤشر نبض الاحتجاجات ومصدر خوف حكم
الملالي جامعه الشريف للتكنولوجيا ومدرسه
النخبه التقنيه في ايران حين تتعالى من
هذا الحرم العريق تتعاظم الصعوبات امام
السلطات والامن للسيطره على مستقبل البلاد
مركز واحتجاجات الثوره
الرئيسيه الحاليه ومصدر الهام 130 جامعه
ينتفظه طلابها بوجه البسيج
لكن لماذا جامعه الشريف هذه نقطه جذب المع
العقول الايرانيه الطلاب التقنيين طلاب
الصناعات وطلاب العلوم النوويه والفضاء
بشكل خاص لطالما كانت هذه التخصصات في عهد
الخميني وخامنئي من بعده تمنح الطلاب
مرتبه اجتماعيه مختلفه وفرصا مؤكده في
المراكز الحساسه وهنا يظهر وجه الاحتجاج
الحقيقي
اجابه احد اعضاء اتحاد طلاب جامعه شريف
الوكاله الفرنسيه
حمام
اذا انا اوالي متابعه كامله في ايران ينضم
الينا من جنيف عبر سكايب تيمور الياسي عضو
منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه من جانب
اهلا بك اذا بدايه سابدا معك بالارقام 700
مراهق اعتقلوا منذ سبتمبر وحتى الان هذا
هو الرقم المعلن هلا يمكن ان يكون العدد
اكبر
منها
قادته
مئه الاف خرجوا الى الشوارع اخر همم لتحدي
هذا النظام والمطالبه بالتغيير
عصفور
لبيانات
المسؤولين الايرانيين
فانا معدله اعمار هؤلاء المعتقل لانه 17
عاما
وليس بالمئات بالالاف وفقا لمعلوماتنا
فانا
ربعها هؤلاء الذين قتلوا من قبل القوات
الامنيه هم القصر اعمارهم او من القاصرين
وهذا انتهاك صار صار
[موسيقى]
وحقوقها الانسان وحقوق المدنيين
وتنتهكه النظام الايراني وهو طرف هذه
المعاهده
المؤشرات والارقام الحقيقيه يعني نتحدث عن
اكثر من سبعين قتيل بين الاطفال هناك ايضا
مؤسسه الدفاع عن الديمقراطيات الامريكيه
تتحدث عن تجنيد الاطفال في ايران يعني
جديده على ان تكون من بين قوه القمع وهذا
اشبه يعني بثوار التميل في السيرلانكا ما
هي الطريقه الحقيقيه التي يمكن التعاطي من
خلالها مع هذه الحاله
امم ولده اسلاميه
كافه السبل فمثلا يذهبون الى السجون
ويخرجون منها المعتقلين والمجرمين ويقولون
من احكامهم ويطلبون منهم المشاركه في قمع
المتظاهرين
فالنظام ليس لديه اي مشكله في قمع الشباب
الايرانيين
وحملتها وشهر اندرسفيل
80% من
الشعب الايراني اعمارهم من الشبه واقل من
30 عاما وهذا
يطالب يتطلب اليه دوليه لمساءله حول
المسؤولين اثناء النظام الايراني الذين
يستخدم
المتظاهرين
الاطفال وهو الذي يعد خلقا لاتفاقيه حقوق
الاطفال التي انضمت اليها ايران في 1994
على العموم
سنتحدث عن لو نعرض الكود لجوزيل
قال اليوم ان مجموعه السبعتناقش كيفيه
استمرار دعم المتظاهرين في ايران ضد القمع
هل هذا يعني انه من الممكن ان يكون هناك
دور او ساعه للمنظمات الحقوقيه في ايران
للتوثيق وايضا ربما التحرك بشكل ما في
ايران
اكيد اكيد
انهم يعملون على مشروع
لادراجي الحرس الثوري
واعتقد بان هذه الطريقه او خطوه جيده
للمضيق دوما
اكس اكس
في مجلس حقوق الانسان الامامي
اللي خلقي الاليات للتحقيق والباحث في
الجرائم التي ارتكبها ال النظام الايراني
منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه في جنيف
[موسيقى]
العمل بالليل من اجل ملايين النهارده
الساعه
بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
في فرنسا تم توفير ملايين الجراح لكن
العمل الليلي في المصانع بدلا من النهار
ورغم الاحتجاجات التي تضرب فرنسا بسبب
الازمه عمال هذه المصانع المتحدون لم
يعترضوا حتى الان من حسني وزاره الصناعه
الفرج الفرنسيه
الى الصواريخ البالسيه والمسيرات وكلاهما
تحول من حرب العصابات الى السيطره على
الدوله
تقريرا لمركز مكافحه الارهاب التي
اكاديميه ويست بوينت العسكريه الامريكيه
رصد التشابه بين الميليشيا ووصل للتركيبه
والهيكليه الداخليه وعلى راسها ما يعرف
اسم مجلس الجهاد السلطه القياديه العليا
للميليشيا الحوثيون استوحو اليه المجلس من
حزب الله والهدف مركزيه المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه وايضا مكافحه التجسس يضم
مجلس الجهاد الحوثي تسعه اشخاص يترقصوا
عبد الملك الحوثي ابرز ما يضم هذا المجلس
مراقبا من المجلس التنفيذي ومسؤولا من
القوات الخاصه ومسؤول المناطق العسكريه
وما يعرف بمساعد الجهاز عفوا النائب الخاص
بك هذا المنظر تحديدا هو مساعد الجهاد
استحدثته طهران في بيروت بغداد وثم ثم وصل
الى صنعاء ويعد بمثابه مستشار العسكري
الاول لزعيم
شاركوا في تحديد نوع المساعده التقنيه
والتدريبات والاجهزه التي تقدمها ايران
وحزب الله وكما هي الحال مع مساعد الجهاد
في كتائب حزب الله في العراق فمساعد
الجهاد في اليمن عميد في الحرس الثوري لم
يذكر التقرير اسمه بينما نائبه من حزب
الله ضابطن ام معروف باسم ابو زينب لكن
رغم التشابه هناك مفارقه النائب اللبنانيه
يتفوق على قائده الايراني وربما يكمون
السر في عامل اللغه والرؤيه الحفيه الاكثر
ميلا الى حزب الله
رغم محاولاته طهران الى عمليه انصهار اكثر
منه تماهن بين الميليشيتين التشابه
والمحاكاه العلاقات الحوثيه لا تقتصر على
ميليشيا ايران المفضله بل تمتد الى
ميليشيات طيران ايضا في العراق ادرج
الحوثيون عددا من ميليشياتهاما في الهيكل
الاداري لوزاره الدفاع سعيا خلف غطاء
شرعيا لتنظيم غير شرعي وبطبع لدفع الاجور
وبعيدا عن المعارك يظهر التعاون بين اذرع
ايران في مجالات اخرى كالاعلام التمويل
والدبلوماسيه في 2019 استغل الحوثيون
اذاعه محليه تدعى سام اف ام لاطلاقه حمله
تبرع لحزب الله تحت عنوان مبادلات الوفاء
بالوفاء والحمله جمعت 130,000 دولار
والعبره هنا ليست بالرقم
وحتى في تشابه المصطلحات وخطابات نصر الله
والحوثي وخلفيه الكروما الاخراجيه وتخصيص
شعار لكل مناسبه تشابهن منطقي بما ان
قناتي الساحات والمسيره الحوثيه فبالتالي
من بيروت الحقيقه ان اهتمام النظام في
طهران بسلاح الاعلام ليس جديده وصفه
خامنئي بالسلاح الاقوى فهو يرى فيه جزءا
لا يتجزا من نهج تصدير التوراه بعد عام
واحد من سيطرته على البلاد وتحديدا في عام
1980 اطلق اذاعه جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه
خدمتها الى اليوم ويختار المرشد الايراني
رئيس الاذاعه كما توفى المدينه الضاحيه
الاعلاميه كما يطلق عليها التدريب والدعم
الفني واعداد المحتوى وهو ما يفسر تكرار
عبارات الاعلام الحربي في مقاطع فيديو كل
من حزب الله الحشد الشعبي
وقوات النظام السوري
[موسيقى]
دنوه من استديو الرياض ينضم الينا مستشار
وزير الاعلام اليمني فهد الشرفي اهلا بك
سيد فهد اذا حتى ما حاله الانصهار هذه بين
الحرس الثوري بين الحوثي وحزب الله
العوامل التي تدفع الحوثيين اكثر باتجاه
حزب الله هل تتمثل او هل تكمن باللغه فقط
باللغه
العوامل التي ماذا
العوامل التي تدفع الحوثيين اكثر باتجاه
حزب الله من الحرس الثوري هل تكمن بشكل
اكبر في اللغه تشارك اللغه
طبعا من حيث التاسيس له اسبقيه كبيره وهو
من اقدم ربما الاذرع الايرانيه التي كانت
خارج الحدود الايرانيه ولديه باع طويل
ايضا في التعامل مع النظام الايراني اضافه
الى ان المذهب الذي يعتنقه اعوذ بالله هو
المذهب الامامي الاثني عشري الجعفري وهو
مذهب ولائه خالص 100% وليس عليه اي شوائب
كثير من العوامل تجعل الاقدميه لحزب الله
رغم ان ربما الحوثيين في الفتره الاخيره
في التوسع والمساحه اصبحوا يسيطرون على
مساحه تفوق بعشرات المرات المساحه التي
يسيطر عليها حزب الله لكن الحزب الله
مشرفا على الحوثيين همم لهذه العوامل وهي
عوامل الاقدميه وعامل ايضا الولائيه حيث
يعتبر الايرانيون ان حسن نصر الله
الحزب الله ولاؤهم بنسبه 100%
للثوره الايرانيه بينما الحوثيين لا زالوا
شيعه تحت التدريب لانه همم ينظر الاماميين
او الجعافره او اتباع المذهب الجعفري الى
الشيعه في انهم شيعه درجه ثانيه او شيعه
درجه ثالثه حتى انه لا يعترف لا يعترف
بامامهم الذي هو الامام زيد بن علي وفي
كتب الاماميه يقولون له لا يقولون الامام
زيد وانما زيد الشهيد هناك فروق عقائديه
كانت ايران انها لا زالت عائجا امام
الحوثي وبالتالي العام او ربما من بدايه
العشر سنوات الاخيره خضع الحوثيين محاوله
اعاده
موضعها فكريه في محاوله لجذبهم اكثر في
التخلي عن المبادئ الزيديه اكثر من
المبادئ الاماميه الجعفريه نعم واذا
تحدثنا ايضا في الاعلام السلاح الاقوى
بحسب خامنا ايه هذا النموذج في ذات القالب
يمكن لي من يتابع سواء اعلام الحوثي او
اعلام حزب الله او اعلام جميع المليشيات
التي تدعمها ايران يعني يجد ان الرساله
واضحه في هذا الاعلام هذه النسخه
الاعلاميه تحديدا الحوثيه هل هناك اساليب
حكوميه لمواجهه ما تقدمها في المقابل
هو لان الاعلام المشروع الايراني في
المنطقه اعلام متجانس ومتغادم
همم
الوسائل الاعلاميه الحوثيه يشرف عليها همم
شخص معروف وهو من قيادات ال- همم حزب الله
وهذا الشخص موجود وكان ياتي الى صنعاء في
2013 فيها اعلامي لبناني وهذا الاعلامي
المشرف على قناه المسيره وقناه الساحات
ووسائل الاعلام الموجوده في الضاحيه
الجنوبيه وهو ايضا الذي درب اضافه الى ان
ايضا للحوثيين باع في الاعلام واشتغلوا
على الاجانب الاعلامي وكانوا يعدوا انفسهم
لانه هذه همم ثورتهم او منهجهم او نهجهم
قائم على الاعلام بصفه رئيسيه اوبترا
راينا انهم يهتمون حتى مساله الاعلام
الحربي حيث بين كل خمسه اعلامي او خمسه
مقاتلين مق الاعلامي اعلام حربي يصور في
المواقع لان
مساله همم يعني تحشيد الناس قائمه على
الرساله الاعلاميه وعلى التصوير واحيانا
تصوير الدرامي يعني ان يغامر الحوثيين
باربعه خمسه يصلون الى موقع معين
ويطلقتهابات معينه انتم لاحظتم انه اثناء
الحرب فعلى الحدود مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الحوثيين قدموا مجموعه اهالي 10
اشخاص ومع مصور الى موقع ربما ان هذا
الموقع ليس موقعا سعوديها ورفع القنبله
وقال كلمه تحولت
انه سلم نفسك يا سعودي وبالتالي هذه
حولوها الى يقولون وضحكوا على عشرات
الالاف
شكرا جزيلا لكم استوديو الرياض مستشار
وزير الاعلام اليمني فهد الشرفي
[موسيقى]
ازمه الغذاء تعوم و تغرق وتعود للواجبات
اتفاق اشبه بهدنه هشه اوقف ثم يدق ناقوس
الخطر
تساؤلات المشروعه عن البدائل الخيار الاول
هو نقل الحبوب الى موانئ بحر البطيق عبر
القطار الميزه هنا هي توفر شبكه سكك
الحديد بالمواصفات الروسيه لكن تم عائقا
مقابل الميزه فابله روسيا التي تطالب برفع
العقوبات عنها مقابل حق عبودي اراضيها
فرنسا التي وقعت قبل تعليقي الاتفاق
تفاهما مع رومانيا لزياده صادرات الحبوب
الاوكرانيه الى الدول الناميه تريد اتجنب
ما وصفته
لنقل الحبوب عبر طريقا بريا للحبوب تنقل
عبر الشاحنات
الى الحدود الهولنديه
والرومانيه
وهناك عائقا اخر لوجستيا هذه المره 23
الشحنات كبرى تعادل وعربه قطار واحده فيما
تلزموا ثلاثه الاف شاحنه لملئ سفينه حبوب
ويعني تكلفه في النقل
تجعل القمح الاوكراني بدون مشترين ازمه
الاقتصاد تضرب العالم ككل
خيار اخر استخدمته كيا قبل اتفاق الحبوب
قد تحاول احيائه طريقنا بطولي
423 كلم عبر مولفا وبنائي كوستنوته في
رومانيا ولكن الطريق البريه باتت مزدحمه
جدا ماذا يعني ذلك كانت الشاحنات تقطع هذه
المسافه في 16 ساعه الان في كم ليست ضعف
ولا الضعيفين
اسبوعا كامل
وبينما تبحث عن حل انفعال خيار في الافق
المبادره الاوروبيه وباختصار ينقل القمح
عبر القطار حتى ميناء جلاتي الروماني
الواقع على نهر الدانوب والميناء يحتاج
فقط لبناء السكه الحديديه واحده بالخصائص
الروسيه وطولها خمسه كيلومترات للربط
وجلاته
بامكانه استقبال كل انواع السفن وبذلك
ستبلغ الشحنات الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر
الذنوب الى المانيا ومرورا بالنمسا وايضا
كرواتيا
اذا اتفاق هو الحبوب المبرم برعايه امميه
شهر يوليو الماضي ورغم استئنافه ولدها
الشمس وبمرور الاسابيع وجدت موسكو سببا
لايقافه وقدمت لها اوكرانيا الحجه
والدريعه على طبق من ذهب
طائرات مسيره على اسطول البحر الاسود في
سبيستون تجاوز للحدود بالنسبه لروسيا متهم
اكياف ومن وراءها لندن بالامر استانفتهم
واثقه لكن
الشروط الجديده
بعد جهود الامميه وتركيا لكن الاهم انها
عادت بضمانات خطيه من اوكرانيا موسكو
اشترطت اولا عدم استخدام الممر الامني
المخصص لمرور السفن المحمله بالقمح لشنه
هجمات ارهابيه على الاراضي الروسيه ثانيا
تصدير الحبوب الى الدول الاكثر احتياجا في
افريقيا واسيا حيث ترى موسكو ان الحبوب لا
تصل لهذه الدول بل للدول الاوروبيه وهي
انتقائيه متحيزه كما تقول موسكو حتى الان
تعتبر هذه الضمانات المكتوبه التي قدمتها
اوكرانيا كافيه لاستئناف هذه الصفقه من
جديد لكن هل تكون كافيه في المستقبل
كم ذكرت مراسلتنا اتهمت روسيا الغرب
بانتقائيه في التوزيع لتطرح خطه لتعويض
القمح الاوكراني خطه بالمجان قد تبدو
كريمه للبلدان الفقيره 500 الف طنا من
الحبوب الروسيه ساتوجه لهذه البلدان وهكذا
نالت استحسان الامم المتحده التي لا طالبت
وجهه اليها سهام الانتقادات لكن
الاوروبيين لا يؤمنون ولا يؤمنون بكرم
روسيا وخصوصا في زمن الحروب اتهموها
بالتسلح لكن بقمح اوكرانيا والغايه
السياسيه بالطبع لكن لماذا هذا الحديث
الغربي عن تسلح روسيا بالخمح كم الغاز
الاجابه فيما فعلته موسكو في المناطق التي
تقع تحت السيطراتها عمليات تهريب معقده
لمقامه لسرقته والعهده هنا على فاينل
تايمز وربما لهذا السبب ضمت روسيا مؤخرا
ضمن اربع مناطق الاقليم يعتبر احد اكبر
مناطق انتاج الحبوب في العالم وفيه اكبر
مخازن الحبوب في اوكرانيا
مصادر محليه اوكرانيه التفاصيل لفاينال
شين تايمز موسكو اسست شركه للحبوب في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه الشركه يديرها رجال
اعمال مقربون من الكرملين والمهم الاساسيه
واضحه شراء القمح من المزارعين
الروايه تتقارب بعض الشيء مع روايه مصدر
عسكري روسي شاحنات عسكريه تتكفل بمهمه نقل
القمح الاورانج برا من روسيا الى مواني
شبه جزيره القرم لتحضيرها للتصدير على
اساس منتجات الروسيه
اما في المرحله الثالثه تشحن الحبوب عبر
موانئ افيدوسيا وسيباسبول بالقرمه او
ميناء بلادي كافكاز بواسطه سفن الروسيه
وسوريه قبل ان تتوجه الى مشترين في تركيا
او تتوجه الى ميناء طرطوس السوري للتمويه
قبل ارسالها الى دول اخرى مثل لبنان
على ذكاء فائق هل تنقلب حريه التعبير على
مطلقها في الساعه
بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
هنا كان استخدام الهالوين
على عكس ما حدث في كوريا الجنوبيه فرقه
الشرطه الخاصه جعلت الهالوين غايه للوصولف
زي الابطال
سبايدر مان
متقلبن غريبه لا يمكنني احد ان يتوقع
خطواته صفات حملها معه لمقر شركه تويتر
مدير تويتر الجديد يريد الفضاء فضاء
الكترونيا يشكله تماما كما فعل مع الفضاء
الخارجي ماسك الملياردير يبحث عن الربح
لكن جنبا الى جنب مع امور عده تقلق الجميع
وغربين معلمين واليوم تحديدا موظفين
اطالتهم مق صله الفصل الجماعي اوله القلق
قرروا انشائي مجلسا جديدا لتنسيق
المنشورات بما يوحي بتخفيف قيود اداره
المحتوى القلق هنا ان العصفور الازرق
باخبار مضلله وخطاب كراهيه وبلا ارشادات
توجيهيه قد يؤدي للعنف ودوله مثل الولايات
المتحده مثلا مقبلا على انتخابات النصفيه
وهنا بدا بعض المغردين اصلا في الخروج من
التويتر بينما ذهب البعض الاخر بتغريدات
تحمل خطابا للكراهيه من اجل تحديد قرارات
ماسك نحوها الحذف ام الابقاء بل طال الامر
ماسك بيحددته غير رذاذ بنشر رابطا لشائعه
حول الهجوم على زوج رئيسه مجلس النواب
نانسي فلوسي قبل ان يحذف التغريده
وكانت هو ابن برج نقلت ارقامنا تظهر ان
خطاب الكراهيه ارتفع في الساعات التي
عاقبت اتمام الصفقه تراس ماسك لاكثر اللي
اكثر طبعا
ماسك اكثر من نصف شهره ونفودا في العالم
يثير القلق حول كيفيه اداره العملاق
الازرق الملك الجديد تعاهد وبدا بتنفيذي
وعوده قالها تويتر ليس مجانيه
التوثيق الزرقاء لكن ما يثير القلق اكثر
حين اشار الى ان الكلام غير المقيد يجب ان
يكون هو القاعده على الموقع
فالمقابل يواجهه ماسك الذي يزعم بانه مطلق
حريه التعبير الضغوط الكبيره وخصوصا فيما
يتعلق بالمعلومات المضلله وخطاب الكراهيه
والتطرف على المنصه وهو ما بدلا فتن وعيد
استحوا به على المنصه نسبه الافتراء
العنصريه ارتفعت 1000 و700 700 في المئه
الف و700 وبلغت ثروتها عندما 2005 اشاره
كل خمس ثواني وذلك وفقا لبياناتنا من
ذاتها ماينر شركه تويتر الرسميه اوروبا
كلها
احتجاجات بسبب اسعار الطاقهقه من تخفيف
الاشراف على المحتوى والمفوض الاوروبي
المكلف بالاشراف على السوق الرقميه شدد
على ان العصفور سيحلق نعم
وابقى القوانين الاوروبيه غير ان المثير
للقلق هو ما يمكن ان يخلقه ماسك من فوضى
اكبر صحيفه نيويورك تايمز وصفت الرجل بانه
اللاعب اساسي في الفوضى الجيو سياسيه كيف
تغريداته بشان مناطق الصراع في العالم مثل
حرب اوكرانيا تظاهرات ايران وازمه الصين
وتايوان
[موسيقى]
ونظرا لان تويتر يتكون من مليارات
التفاعلات يوميا يمكن اعتباره بمثابه ذكاء
الكترونيا جماعيا فائقه ما ادخل تعديلات
بسيطه
تغريده كتبها ماسك بعد الاس ده اعرف قطع
صورته صغيره لكن هل عليه ان يقلق من هذا
الذكاء الفائق الى ماسك في جحيم تويتر
عنوانه مقالنا ان شره موقع ذا بيرج
المتخصص بشؤون التكنولوجيا والسؤال لماذا
جحيم ان كان يريد ماسك زياده اعداد
المستخدمين للموقع وبالتالي زياده عائدته
لا يملك الا ان يقدم تنازلات وبعض هذه
التنازلات لها ضريبه فالمشكلات التي
يواجهها تويتر ليست هندسيه وانما سياسيه
وياتي على راس اولويات المنصه الاهتمام
بالمستخدمين مما جعلهم بمثابه الاصول
المهمه لموقع تويتر وهو ما يعقد الامر
اكثر لذا يجب الحفاظ على استقطابهم
واستمرهم في نشره تغريدات وماسك واحد منهم
اي انه دفع اربعه واربعين مليار دولار من
شراء نفسه
الحقيقه ان ماسك بين ميزان حريه التعبير
والقانون لذا عليه وفق الكاتبه حضر بعض
العبارات بحسب القانون اذا كان يريد كسب
المال وفي هذه الحاله سيكون عرضه للانتقاد
من الاجيال الشابه اليمنينيه لكن ماذا عن
خارج الحدود الامريكيه على سبيل المثال
لنقول المانيا تعد سوقا كبيرا لسيارات
شركه تسلا التي يمتلكها ماسك والامر نفسه
موجود في الهند وكذلك في العديد من الدول
الاخرى ومنها امريكا بالطبع بشان المحتوى
الذي يتم نشره عبر شبكات التواصل بهذه
المناسبات
يحاولون تدمير حريه التعبير
[موسيقى]
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه على الابواب
وازمات الاقتصاد على راس الاولويات لكن
هناك باب اخر تواربه الاداره ولا تصده وقد
يخلعه اصلا من اساسه هواء الشتاء القادم
البارد جدا التضخم هناك ازمه جديده
ستفاقمه والعهده على صحيفه ذهن ليس
البنزين وان ديزل مخزون الديزل
في 25 يوما مستوى المنخفض جدا لم يحدث منذ
2008 وتعتمد عليه الشاحنات والحافلات نعم
لكنه يستخدم في التدفئه ايضا ونحن مقبلون
على الشتاء هناك عوامل فرضته على اسواق
الديزل ومن بينها كميه الوقود المقطر في
المخازن ارقام نواتج التقدير التقدير
متقاربه للغايه وهو امر مؤلم وهكذا يوضح
رئيس تحليل البنزين في شركه فادي التي
تحلل اسعار الوق
[موسيقى]
سنترك الجدل حول ما اذا كانت كميات الديزل
لا اساتن جانبا كما عوضنا كم سناخذكم الى
المستقبل
[تصفيق]
التجاريه تزيد الطين بالله وربما الافضل
ان ناخذ القطار المترو ايضا الانشاءات
ستؤخرنا اكثر
ما الذي حدث نفذ الديزل هلا كل ما يتحرك
حولنا وقوده جزيئات الديزل في امريكا نعم
وحتى السفن بالمناسبه التي تبحر من اوروبا
الى هنا ومن الصين الى الساحل الغربي
للولايات المتحده هل فعلا ستتعطل الحياه
حالته الشلل هذه تحتاج الى حل فوري
والحلول غير متوفره ولا نتحدث هنا عن
المركبات الكهربائيه فنحن في ثالث اكبر
سوق لها لان عدد المركبات منها في الشارع
لا يذكر قياسها ببلدا مثل الولايات
المتحده ولا زالت الدراجات البخاريه التي
تعمل بالرياح والشاحنات الكهربائيه غير
جاهزه حتى الان ونحن في الشتاء
كان يمكن ان لاسوء السيناريوهات ان تتحقق
كان يمكن للشتاء الاوروبي المرتقب ان يكون
ملكيا ايضا وكما ذكرنا الاعتماد هنا على
الديزل للتدفئه اساسي مشاهدينا عاده
الحركه لكن النص يبقى قائما يرجح اذا ان
يغذي التضخم الشتاء وان يدخل الديزل ضمن
العوامل المؤثره على الانتخابات المرتبه
بحسب وكاله
وصلنا الى نهايه الساعه 60 ونوات تتابعون
غدا في العراق هل يستطيع السوداني الوقوف
في وجه منجا به الاطار
والثلاثيه الثلج الرمل والوحل لمن ستلعب
في روسيا ام لاوكرانيا
في نهايه الساعه ابرزوا احداث الساعه
بالصور من الان وحتى الساعه المقبله انا
حنين
[موسيقى]